all right today's Thursday crew roll dog
woke us up to this and then next Dean I
go in the kitchen and he's got the
freaking dakine brewing and he made us a
killer killer power breakfast start
calling dr. dr. watch in the Vitamix
this morning for breakfast this is the
secret listen up choice for the Durance
athlete here's what we got going yeah
tomato kale beets key endurance formula
red pepper carrot celery a little
organic lemonade and then some once we
put in there oh you know we didn't do
the flax oil with coconut oil no we did
chia seeds then we did chia seeds and
maca first the cheetah over here we have
the white cheetah with the maca root
powder and we had a one small mine in
Hawaii one sea salt in there and some
lemon
thanks Michelle from Kauai for sipping
it out to us we have like all of our
friends are like sending us grub and
stuff in the mainland so they would have
to pay 29.99 for a jar of almond butter
but anyways we're about to bounce out
we're not going to tell you what we're
doing today yet because we actually want
to accomplish it so we'll tell you after
what we're doing after what we did but
it's a beautiful day here in Kailua Kona
looks like it's going to be clear we
can't see Maui but a roll dog Lester out
peace